hi I'm ISA ray hey I'm Mark Martin hi
I'm Regina Hall we can take it new in
theaters this weekend the curse of La
Llorona this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
the reaping woman mr. [ __ ] down
to sum this sixth installment in the
contouring universe is an adaptation of
the story made infamous and Mexican
folklore about the weeping woman who did
you try to stop I don't know in this
movie while investigating one of her
cases a social worker named Anna Garcia
discovers not only foul play but
supernatural hauntings by the terrifying
ghost
full of don't go in there moments and
feelings of oh why this movie is sure to
keep you up for the next few nights this
movie is for you if you're a fan of any
of the conjuring movies you're impressed
by the acting chops of scared Linda
Cardellini or La Llorona is your
favorite song from the neck lalala la
Llorona I tried I tried that is your
weekend ticket I hope you don't yourself
and check back next week for the last
Avengers movie ever Oh probably not cuz
money
[Music]